Bobby Moynihan is leaving Saturday Night  Live what did I get that from yeah I  heard it from my lotion guys slippery  Jerry  [Music]  et can confirm the 40-year old actor  will not be returning to the NBC sketch  comedy series after nine seasons this  isn't about me I'm doing it for the  people of easily  this comes after Bobby's new show me  myself and I got picked up by CBS and  will premiere in the fall  et spoke with the comedian during the  CBS upfronts presentation in New York  City where he was there promoting the  new series on Wednesday will you be able  to do both series are you gonna be on me  myself and I strictly see what a fun  question that's not terrifying at all  [Applause]  [Music]  you